so season two we're back again with
detective Joe and diesel Riley of diesel
takes on my finger hole this season at
the beginning of season one you know we
saw her come in as this fresh outta cat
and me wide-eyed optimistic rookie and
by the end of it you know she's lost her
partner so we're picking that up right
where we left off she's sort of alone
and abandoned and we get to see sort of
her progression and she gets to
experience some of the hard lessons that
the mean streets of neo doctor City
teaches so long for season well I think
the most intense thing we did was like
fall onto a path this season we'll
really put into his paces we have a
hand-to-hand action sequence that you
know he'd learned and spent days sort of
choreographing and getting super sore
for we definitely bruised him up a
little bit for this season aside from
that what we'll be pulling from a
handful of folks that we know and love
from the
crunchyroll anime community as well as
sort of see some new faces I think from
the casting standpoint season two is
going to be full of fun vibrant
characters that you know we had a lot of
fun to shoot and we hope people have a
kick out of watching
[Music]